[Music]
hey everybody happy mondays so there's
just a big infinity war Avengers for
expose that dropped where pretty much
everybody in the Marvel Universe did
this big interview with a cover shoot
for Vanity Fair so obviously they're
hyping everything up but within their
interview they talked a lot about what's
happening with the culmination of their
big phase 3 arc and Avengers 4 and how
everything's gonna look so different
afterwards in the Marvel cosmic universe
separately from that you also probably
notice that the Russos just quietly
dropped this picture of a three denoting
that there would probably be a trailer
for infinity war coming in either three
days or on December 3rd we'll talk about
that too but I already did that video
for the leaked footage so I'll add a
link for that at the end of this most of
that will be in the Infinity war trailer
when they drop it but if you are finding
me for the first time there's a bunch of
Marvel stuff happening through the rest
of the year so be sure to subscribe to
get everything and I'm still doing that
movie ticket giveaway I'll explain at
the end of the video but talking about
all the Avengers for infinity war stuff
Kevin Feige was teasing you may have
seen the video I posted from behind the
scenes of this big Avengers shoot where
Mark Ruffalo accidentally teased Groot
Hulk team-up stuff obviously we knew
that that would happen eventually
because the guardians are crossing over
with the Avengers in these next two
movies
[Music]
but now we know a little bit more about
what was going on they were doing this
huge interview to celebrate the 10th
anniversary of Marvel Studios which is
going to coincide with the theatrical
release of infinity war so in addition
to doing infinity war stuff they're also
sort of caps toning all the stuff that's
come before in what we've come to know
is the Marvel Cinematic Universe is now
sort of transitioning to become the
Marvel cosmic universe which I don't
think it's going to replace all of the
Marvel stuff but based on what Kevin
Feige has been saying is is most of
their development energy is gonna be
going into these cosmic movies the James
Gunn has started to work on now that
he's in the process of making guardians
3 and they did confirm the guardians 3
is sort of the tip off for this broader
Marvel cosmic universe so when you think
of Marvel Cinematic Universe phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 think of the cosmic
universe as the exact same thing just a
series of phases although I'm sure it'll
be just a little bit different like they
don't want things to be as cookie cutter
as they have been before but they're
still gonna be a schedule they'll still
be movies that get sequels we might even
get a fourth Thor movie based on the
fact that the director wants to come
back Chris Hemsworth wants to come back
so it's not either completely abandoning
all the earth-based films and even
though spider-man is gonna go into outer
space
obviously the spider-man sequel is
probably going to be set on earth so
it's not like all of a sudden all the
characters in the movies are just gonna
go into outer space and it's going to be
Marvel cosmic stuff from here on out but
in conjunction with this they also
detailed a very candid history of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we've talked
about it at various points like when we
got ready for Civil War there was a lot
of drama with the deal they tried to
make for the spider-man character how
Marvel Studios broke for Marvel proper
and sort of separated from Marvel TV and
went off by itself the backstory on it
all is fascinating even James Gunn talks
about
some of the problems he had with Marvell
while he was making guardians of the
galaxy so they used a couple different
terms to denote the different eras of
Marvel Studios they're sort of the
inception at the beginning when Avi Arad
was still there where they sort of
started to make their own films when the
first Iron Man film Incredible Hulk
started to be made and then in success
the early Feige years when a via rod was
like alright I'm done I don't want to
deal with all this bureaucracy I just
want to make movies and that's it
so he anointed Kevin Feige he became
president of Marvel Studios and they
proceeded with phase 1 under sort of
like the CEO of Marvel proper Ike
Perlmutter so you may have heard sort of
the behind-the-scenes drama of what that
era was like it was like a very business
penny-pinching era where they're like ok
we're all about making money we need to
make the broadest appealing films
possible sand off all the interesting
edges just make us the movies that will
make us the most amount of money so
naturally there were a lot of clashes
behind the scenes you hear about all the
creative fights they used to have this
is when James Gunn also said he had some
issues with Marvel's creative committee
which is when they were still advising
on the film's so there was a group of
people there was Bendis Joe Quesada
a bunch of other Marvel comic book
writers and industry people who would
try to do the same thing that Lucasfilm
story group does for the people that
make Star Wars movies just sort of like
handle the continuity make sure that
they weren't going to off-book with the
characters one of the funny notes the
James Gunn's said he got really upset by
was when they said that he needed to get
rid of the 70s music and guardians of
the galaxy so you have to imagine this
group of creative comic-book people
telling him no don't don't do that and
that wound up being one of the biggest
things about the movie that people liked
the album that they published of those
collected songs from the first mixtape
went platinum super fast so very clearly
early on there were a couple different
camps within Marvel and Marvel Studios
you had the people that had like a
really good idea for building a
cinematic universe then you had people
that were sort of in charge of all the
business decisions and they just fought
with each other a lot while they were
making these movies but then they get
bought out by Disney and you finally
have someone with the authority to
overrule the people that typically
overrule Kevin Feige on decisions in
get to go off on their own and do their
own thing so if you ever wondered why
there's not a black widow movie that was
a business decision because the Marvel
CEO told Kevin Feige that female
superheroes don't sell toys Kevin Feige
says that he actually wanted to
introduce Captain Marvel before Wonder
Woman made it to the screen and then
when Wonder Woman did gang busters they
planned their like see you can make a
female lead superhero movie that people
will love will make a ton of money it
can actually be a good story so it was
just sort of the proof in the pudding so
now that Marvel is off on its own it can
pretty much do whatever it wants which
is where you get to Marvel cosmic
universe beyond the Marvel Cinematic
Universe what does that actually mean
for Avengers for Kevin Feige says
there's going to be a finale meaning
that they'll actually will transition
out of some of the super heroes like we
might actually see Captain America die
and Chris Evans won't come back there
are a lot of you that are pointing at
this Thor spread and they're like hey
wait a minute how come he just has the
scar over his one eye here so we'll say
careful for spoilers for Thor Ragnarok
if you haven't seen that movie yet I
feel like it's been long enough that
people who care about spoilers have
probably seen it but there were even
people on my infinity war video that I
posted yesterday who were like how come
you didn't say spoilers for Thor
Ragnarok but Thor he's standing there
with a big scar over his eye he has
Mjolnir which is whole the reason why
you're seeing him like this is because
they don't want to completely give away
the end of that movie because there are
always a lot of people that just wait
for the DVD release or people in other
countries that don't have access to the
movies but there are a lot of people
that have wondered about what they'll do
with his one eye like will he go full
Odin through both of the next Avengers
films or will Doctor Strange use his
skills as a surgeon as well as the time
gem to give him his eye back or will
someone else just simply heal him up so
that's why the scar is there they could
always do that if they don't want to do
the pirate version of Thor even though
you know I think he could look pretty
badass with one eye but like earlier
this summer we had the comic-con
infinity war footage I did a video for
that and in that footage
he didn't look any different than he
looked at the beginning of Thor Ragnarok
he had both of his eyes people were like
what's going on how come it's like this
here and how come he's so different at
the end of Thor Ragnarok the thing about
that is
is that a lot of his eye in thor
ragnarok a lot of the effects for him
losing it or done in post-production so
it's almost like a Photoshop filter so
when they did that infinity war Comic
Con footage they didn't want to spoil
thor ragnarok because the movie hadn't
been released yet
getting to the Russos trolling everybody
with that three what that could mean is
it could mean the infinity war trailer
is dropping in three days it could be on
December 3rd which is actually a Sunday
so we'll know pretty quickly but
whenever that happens I'll totally do a
video for
is there any infinity war or Avengers
videos that you guys want me to do
between now and then just let me know in
the comments the real big thing that's
happening tonight is is that the DC TV
crossover is happening it's basically a
four hour movie so it's two hours
tonight and two hours tomorrow so
obviously I'll be doing videos for that
but there is a new round of the IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video congratulations to
the winner from my last infinity war
video buyer and James please private
message meet so I can get your contact
details
I'll just announce a new winner when I
post new Marvel you can click here for
my breakdown of the leaked trailer from
yesterday and you can click here to get
ready for that big DC TV crossover
tonight thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight